[Funny Music]
Abdul Rahman Al Sayed: We established this company
In 2012.
Then, if you want to read Arabic news on mobile
It was very confusing.
We decided to solve this problem
Create a custom Arabic news reader application
He can collect all the news
And submit them to the right person
Depending on the person's preferences and location.
Abdullah Al Sayed: Android has a majority
Market share of smartphones in the Middle East
So we realized that deploying the Nabd application "pulse" on Android
Was a key factor for our success.
Since we launched the Nabd application "Pulse" on Google Play
We noticed widespread application spread in a very short time.
Currently, 60% of users use the primary Android system.
The number of daily installs for our Android app has increased
As compared to other basic systems.
The rate of user interaction with the application of Nabd "pulse" has increased significantly.
Users can share news and add it to favorites
Or comment on them from within the Nabd Forum "Pulse".
Every three months, more than 7 million stories are available
Shared across social networks
Through Android users and we discovered that
The average number of stories shared per user
20% higher on Android compared to other platforms.
One reason for increased interaction on Android is
Apply what is known as "multidimensional design".
When the multidimensional design was announced
We were impressed by the new visual style
And the possibilities offered by this design.
It took us three months to redesign the entire application
Moving to a three-dimensional design.
One major change is the new version
In adding formatting to multidimensional design tabs.
A section has also been moved from the side menu
To format the tabs we discovered that
Number of users who have discovered
This section doubled by 400%.
After the redesign of the application
We've used our store listing experiments
To discover the best screenshots
The best order for screen shots
So that the largest number of application installations are acquired.
We also found that there was a video in the app install card
The number of conversions increases by 8%.
Multidimensional design has a great impact
In user behavior.
For us, the happiest thing is knowing
Five-star ratings have tripled
After the new version.
We constantly use Google Analytics to identify
Behavior of users and how they interact with the application
Based on our analysis, we improve application design
For best results.
Abdul Rahman Al-Sayed: Three years ago,
There was no application named Nabd "Pulse".
Today, we have more than 25 people across 4 offices
In Kuwait, Saudi Arabia, Dubai and Egypt
And very soon in Turkey.
This is great.
I feel the joy and enthusiasm I can not really describe.